[Musica]
bonjour siamo tornati su harry stigma
avevamo fatto l'altra volta
comunque questa cosa qua la giunta nella
soundboard perché sono uno youtuber
punto perché sono youtuber moderno
questa roba non si usava nel 2015 beh io
spero che vi sia piaciuto altri episodi
di harry stickman che era quello del
skype in the prison cioè sono altri tre
da fare che sono infiltrati in
discipline complex e stile in the
diamond oggi facciamo inflitti
infiltrati in dieci più in inglese
ragazzi purtroppo speriamo ci sia da
tradurre anzi l'agcom e france inter
deve essere così cattiva cosa è successo
i feel trentin di euro ship ok vescovi
non so non mi ricordo niente di quello
che mi hanno trovato la scusa come ci
sono finito io qua e sottanelli ore
spiega mi sento di tradurli che cosa è
successo anche se non credo di aver
capito molto io vi sto trovato qua c'e
non mi hanno preso perché mi devi
infiltrare in questo è ship però non ho
ben capito qual è la trama perché io
l'inglese non lo faccio
direi tra tutti di usare sticky and che
mi sembra l'amore in modo più giusto di
entrare esatto ma se qualcuno di voi ce
l'aveva con loro ce l'ho fatta intanto è
da zitti zitti ci hanno fatto veramente
pensavo di parlare agata 0 poi energy
sto gioco è tutto strano quindi non non
fateci caso se appunto
proviamo a gli altri assoluto grapple
gun e testata che ho dato a presente in
ogni modo ma deve entrare allora weight
aspettiamo che qualcuno esca non esce
nessuno sa se è uscito uno ha funzionato
ma qualsiasi cosa clicco funziona come
possibile c'è la chiave computer
research top secret
chi sta facendo ma si è messo a giocare
si è messo a giocare videogiochi salve
facciamo 20 anni o nell'evento le
gemelle nei avete capito
eccolo quello devo prendere un diamante
c'è una stanza in questo è il chip che è
la stanza più puoi portare via cosa e
costosissime speriamo questa cosa non
l'avevo capitano dedotta adesso
treasuries mio dio sono dei chewing gum
musica preso la mano sono è stato mister
fantastic torna indietro se le porte
perché il teleporto e almeno mettono
sempre in tutti gli episodi dove che
sono
secondo me no retry l'ip ce la farà
prima azzeccato tutto ma niente ok era
giusto in realtà personale persona di
qua perfetto wizard magic no non posso
non usare questo scusatemi beh non è la
bacchetta a scegliere il mago signor
potere trai facciamo hack prova ad
hackerare il cugino salvatore aranzulla
[Musica]
mi sa che dico io
vedrai pay per aizone successo non
diventa sono diversi no vabbè fermi
fermi mi sarei imbucato io nel mezzo ai
compiti in classe la mezza le verifiche
ce l'ha fatta
so fortissimo sono entrato come
possibile se ne fai visto mega gioiello
cloud claw back dei caro fior bard
sharing grau credo sia l'unica cosa che
rimpicciolisce a chiamarti siamo sono
arrivati rinforzi ragazzi la guerra la
guerra vera madonna sono ancora vivo
l'importante che cio gioiello poi vabbè
stiamo mio dio che casino scudo power
armor propano ombrello è lo scudo di
cielo il guscio più che altro dire di
mario kart so perché mi è venuta la
parola scudo rossano morto power
ombrella bene
sì ma gira in tondo sono non è anche
solo morso con il prescindere vedrai
power armor iron man rega
e vabbè è diventato gigante anche il
colon ragazzi è successo un casino
e vabbè cose pacco a tutti prototype e
rave che è successo ragazzi sta
succedendo l'impensabile dal chiedono
rubare una roba la guerra più totale
incredibile quindi posso fare mila tra
mano a chi si è fermato a pisciare va
bene io ho potuto la tuta e quindi
ho vinto lode drift sbloccato uno dei
finali penso sia uno dei tanti è stato
fichissimo dai ragazzi visto che sono un
miliardo di finali problemi del reset i
posti kids and e vedere se riesco a fare
qualcosa tra le cose che posso fattivo
ball and chain perché chi sa che ci sono
più finali a sto punto perché forse no
forse non ci sono più filante ho
sbagliato io così c'è la partenza non è
del perfetto finito era potevo fare così
subito gli ho fregato la cassa fa mi sa
che no allora tra le robe che mancano
cannon ball che mi ricordavo che c'è un
modo per fregarli proprio tutto layer
schiff c'è ancora più del gioiello
ciao ce l'ho fatta
e bravo premio premio premio sì però
devi muovere un po il culetto veloce
velocissimo
il successo ci sono
riproviamo mettiamo fagioli
non so per quale motivo adesso ho capito
però sono vivo importante quello metal
band rock e the rock and jump subito non
è anche ci penso
perfetto era meglio pensare ma vero già
fatta coi e e vabbè con lo yo yo con la
spada ma per certo che quello io io non
potrei avere non potrei avere altre armi
sono questa del writing the right and
men te no vabbè veramente gonzalo che
spa è undertake ho vinto io sono
bravissimo c'era veramente l'ho battuto
subito glider cioè la questa è la più
razionale quello che avrei usato subito
infatti grazie grazie mille
era molto semplice.questa tra tutte ci
siamo ragazzi dovrei l'ho preso open mi
ha dato lerci adesso rispetto a quello
che avevo prima direi che è molto adesso
ci penso due volte tornano indietro non
ci torniamo proprio
facciamo pare che dove missile missile
appunto sull'elicottero
ci ho provato e vabbè possiamo farlo
subito
thank anche se non vedo come i fatti
forse assistono b come come faccio
essere vivo va beh un po un gioco
fantasy nel caso non ce ne fossimo
accorti in realtà il documento che
certifica che eri stick men è stato
perdonato per tutti i crimini e babe
fammi finire ma siccome io in un
criminale mi hanno assoldato per per
fare questa cosa per poi assolvermi
crimini questa era la trama e l'ho
capita adesso c'è un altro finale tipo
con le marionette la faccia fanno finta
che siano noi sono scaltri si dice
comunque speri che pensi che stiano bene
ciao quindi finito così
ragazzi
devo fare così subito a saperlo prima
quindi questo è il finale che preferisco
quello che mi prendo proprio tutto lei
ship che è meglio di tutto penso va bene
ragazzi questo era infiltrata in dieci
per il prossimo che faccio il field
complex e poi farò se in italia non
comunque questi qua di harry stickman
sono in assoluto i giochi in flash più
belli che io abbia mai giocato su c'è in
generale proprietà nostri stickman e poi
da questo quale era venuto in mente
steve fight però c'è questi sono
insuperabili secondo me ce ne mancano
ancora due prende complex senite daimon
ci vediamo poi il prossimo episodio di
hamsik ma cosa i ragazzi seguite
piaciuto al momento è un bel mi piace
anche vari social che come noi lontane
descrizione cioè non aver si schieri e
rai come al solito scegliamo conseguito
grazie
[Musica]